CAN I HAVE A LITTLE RITUAL.
IN THIS COMMITTEE.
RIGHT.
WE HAVE THE ESEE MARCHING BAND
COMING IN.
WE GOT A WAY FOR THEM
[inaudible]
ANYWAY SO -- GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE OUR
VETERANS PLEASE STAND TO GET
RECOGNIZED.
AND YOU WILL NOTICE OUR FLAGS
THAT ARE HERE WE'RE THE ONLY
ONLY.
A COMMITTEE ROOM WITH OUR FLAGS
ON WIENER ARMY NAVY AIRFORCE
RECORD COAST GUARD MUCH MARIE SO
TO OUR VETERANS WOULD YOU PLEASE
STAND UP AGAIN.
THANK YOU AGAIN.
I DO THIS EVERY SINGLE MEETING.
AND AND I APPRECIATE OUR
VETERANS IT IN THE HOUSE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN.
OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE EVENTS
FIRST WILL NOW COME TO ORDER.
AT THIS TIME WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHICH WE
WON'T HALF RIGHT NOW FOR A
LITTLE BIT.
AND THEN WE WILL -- BUT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND AND HERE.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE AND CHAU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
GO AHEAD AND PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT BILLS OFF OF CURRENT LAW
AND WOULD SIMPLY REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BAR. TO
COORDINATE PRO BONO CIVIL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO ACTIVE DUTY
SERVICE MEMBERS VETERANS AND
THEIR FAMILIES YOU CAN OTHERWISE
NOT AFFORD LEGAL SERVICES.
THIS BILL EXPANDS ON AB THREE
SIXTY FROM TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WHICH REQUIRED THE CALIFORNIA
STATE BAR TO COORDINATE PRO BONO.
CIVIL LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOR
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT EXPLICITLY
INCLUDES ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS AS WELL.
AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA HAS IS THE LARGEST
VETERANS POPULATION IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION VETERANS.
AND IS HOME TO OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND STATIONED
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS.
AND ALMOST SEVENTY THOUSAND OF
THEIR SPOUSES STATION RIGHT HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER 60% OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE IN THE FIRST FIVE
AND LISTED PAY GRADES.
CONNECTING SERVICE MEMBERS AND
FAMILIES TO ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDING PRO BONO LEGAL AID TO
INCLUDE REPRESENTATION WILL FILL
A MUCH NEEDED GAP.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORT AND DIE AND
EAST AND REDUCE OUR SPORTY HERE
TO TESTIFY I SAID RIVAS WITH AND
THAT -- GONNA HOLD OFF WE DO
HAVE A FORM NOW.
I'M SICK OF ROLE.
ACTUALLY.
GROWTH O'DONNELL.
NIELSEN ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WILL PRESENT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO WE WILL BE ABLE TO VOTE ON
YOUR BILL.
OKAY GO AHEAD PRESENT YOUR
WITNESS.
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF AMVETS POST NINE FORTY
IN FOLSOM CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT AMERICAN
GI FORUM AMVETS CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY VETERANS
SERVICE OFFICERS CALIFORNIA
STATE COMMANDERS VETERANS
COUNCIL.
MILITARY OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
CHAPTERS IN THE VIETNAM VETERANS
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON SUPPORTED THIS.
THANK YOU.
YEAH IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE.
YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
AB FIVE FIVE EIGHT IS TO PASS.
ARCHULETA.
ACTUALLY I A GROUP.
BOTTOM.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE ROTH AYE.
AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL.
WILL I ASSEMBLYMEMBER THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL TO US I
THINK GREAT SERVICE TO OUR
VETERANS AND THANK YOU SENATOR.
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THE I HAVE A MOTION MOVED
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I WOULD CALL THE ROLL YES SIR.
AB.
TWO THIRTY AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
FIVE THEY HAVE ALL THE SAME
ACTION [inaudible]
AND THE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
TO PASS BUT FIRST REFERRED
PREPARATIONS WITH RECOMMENDATION
TO CONSENT ARCHULETA HI ARTS
LETTER HI GROUP.
THE TITLE.
NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN AYE ROCK.
ROCK I NUMBER.
NUMBER I WILL HI WILL RISE TO
THAT THIS.
YEAH WE'RE GONNA HOLD IT OPEN
AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL.
REMAINING AND WILL HAVE YOU
CENTERED BACK -- ON THE FLOOR
WHERE WE GOTTA GO IN JUST A
MINUTE [inaudible]
YEAH.
SHOW OF TO BRING CERVANTES AND
TO BE.
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL THANK
YOU
.
BUT THE PACKAGE
AB FIVE FIVE
EIGHT TO PASS GROWTH RICARDO.
HOW DO I?
FEEL JUST PASS OUT IN.
DO YOU PASSED.
SHE TO CONSENT.
GROWTH.
RICARDO RICARDO EYES THAT SIX
ZERO THAT PASSES OUT
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible] FIVE RIGHT
NO
.
RIGHT.
WE ARE [inaudible]
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YEAH AND YOU ARE.
SHOULD BE WELCOME YEAH
[inaudible]
HERE WHY.
YOUR CHAIR AND SENATORS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY NINE TODAY --
MORE MISTER TURN CENTERS THIS
BILL IMPLEMENTS CHANGES TO THE
DPP PROGRAM IN RESPONSE TO THE
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN STAY
AUDITOR'S REPORT.
WHICH FOUND AMONG AMONG OTHER
THINGS AT THE DEPARTMENT BILL TO
MAINTAIN APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT
AND RECORD KEEPING PROTOCOLS ON
CONTRACTS INVOLVING D. B. B. E..
AB EIGHT NO NINE ADDRESSES THREE
CORE ISSUES THEN THE AUDITS THEY
INCLUDE. ONE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF DVDS PARTICIPATING IN
STATE CONTRACTING. TO ENHANCE
SEEN OUR TRACKING EVALUATION
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES AND THREE TO
IMPROVE MANAGEMENT AND
OPERATIONAL CONTROLS IN THE DVB
PROGRAM.
I WE DID FINALIZING MOMENTS TO
DRESS THE OPPOSITION'S OUR
CONCERNS AND I KNOW THAT THAT
HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED -- THE
REMOVAL OF THE OPPOSITION HAS
BEEN DOCUMENTED IN SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE.
WITH ME TODAY ARE A NUMBER OF
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I AND IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
ALLOW THEM TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF AFRICA
VARGAS FOR THE UNITED STATES
VETERANS BUSINESS ALLIANCE.
ACCOUNTING OVER THREE HUNDRED
MEMBER OR A COMPANIES AND
INDIVIDUALS -- BOTH THAT ARE
EITHER.
VETERAN OR DISABLED VETERANS AND
WHERE THIS PROUD SPONSORS THIS
BILL.
THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR WORKING
WITH US THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
AS WELL.
BY THE OF NO OPPOSITION AND BE
MOVING THIS BEFORE.
MISTER CHAIR PHIL VERMAELEN
REPRESENTING THE COALITION SMALL
AND DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESSES
WE DID HAVE SOME CONCERNS WHICH
WE ARTICULATED IN A LETTER.
AND I'M HAPPY THAT WE'VE WORKED
OUT SOME AMENDMENTS AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE THE BILL MUCH
BETTER.
AND WE HAVE A FOUR YEAR SUNSET
TO SEE HOW THINGS WORK AND WE
FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
AND IT'S OUR PLEASURE AND HONOR
TO BE ABLE SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION TODAY.
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
IS ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
I SEE NONE.
I HAVE.
A MOTION TO MOVE.
BEFORE WE VOTE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTERS OKAY PLEASE
CALL FOR THE VOTE.
AB EIGHTEEN ZERO NINE DO PASSED
THE FIRST GROUP GROUP
PREPARATIONS ARCHULETA HI.
EXCELLENT I GREW.
DONNA.
THE TOTAL AYE NIELSEN AYE IRA.
I NUMBER NUMBER I WILL.
LOOK.
AT SIX HEARING BILL YOU DON'T
EVEN NEED A CLOSING THOUGHT
THANK YOU KAREN SENATORS.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT LEVEL OF OUR VETERANS
THANK YOU.
I THINK WE'RE BUT OKAY.
THANK YOU EVERYONE.
SESSIONS